hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
Monday
August 21st
every other day every every day of the
[__] week I feel fine yeah
I would never understood that lyric
every other day I feel fine you feel
fine on a [__] Tuesday
you know I'm sick of Monday getting [__]
all right
you walk in you're still half in the bag
by the time you even realize you're at
work the [__] day is half over
the the day that kills used to kill me
when I had the 925 what a way to make a
living right I used to work with Dolly
Parton
oh was she sassy the way she [__]
turned that boss's goddamn slacks around
um Tuesday
's the [__] Monday you get like
I'm saying you know what I mean like
just your head's still spinning you had
a good time you're a little rest up but
Tuesday
Tuesday's reality
Tuesday you come in
after a sober night's sleep hopefully
unless you're on your way to a program
the program
friends with Bill
um and I'm not talking about me there oh
geez I'm talking about the guy with the
[__] Gin Blossom in the middle of his
face there
like you clicked on a special place on
Google Maps over there
um Tuesday
Tuesday was the day you came in sober
you had no fun the day before you had no
relaxation and then that's when it
that's when the job is like real like
[__]
every decision every test I made every
person I broke up with has led to me
sitting here today on a [__] Tuesday
and I got four more of these days coming
Tuesday nothing dragged
like 8 30 to 10 15. I remember that
first [__] that's only an hour and 45
minutes it felt like half the [__]
day it felt like four hours before the
Roach Coach would show up
it would pull into the parking lot and
everybody would spill out of the [__]
warehouse and go down there
remember there was this dude used to get
the [__] hot dogs off of that thing I
mean he never got sick
never got I didn't remember what I used
to get the Roach Coach you go down there
I was young some days I would go down
there I get the cookie with the m m in
it and that's what I would have if I did
that at my age at 10 30 in the morning I
would get halfway through the cookie
then my eyes would start getting heavy
and I would start telling everyone that
could hear that I should not have done
what I just did you know because you
know when you get old everybody's got to
hear about your [__] mistakes and
your ailments right and then about 15
minutes later the yawning would start
and about 23 minutes after the ingestion
I would be phased up
and that would be it I mean I'm talking
like REM sleep
trying to get rid of the sugar that was
on top of all the sugar I've eaten up
until that point
um
so anyway what what exactly is it that
I'm taught what am I really
trying to say here
um I'm trying to say that I have a new
date everybody in Rama Ontario October
6th at the Casino Rama Resort
I don't even remember saying yes to this
[__] I feel like my age is just [__]
throwing dates now pre-sales he's going
to hear this and be like oh there's some
sort of problem but there's any sort of
communication issue that we need to work
out
I'm [__] around if you're listening
Mike uh pre-sale starts Wednesday I'm
actually not [__] around I don't
remember this I'm sure I said yes to it
I'm sure you called me when I was
driving down the [__] highway trying
to scroll to the next AC DC song What
where all right [__] it I'll do it so
now I'm doing it people
October 6th at the Casino Rama Resort
pre-sale starts on Wednesday
10 a.m eastern time with the code Burr
b-u-r-r the General on sale is August
25th at 10 A.M where can we go for the
ticket Link at
www.bilber.com for the ticket link
and there you have it well anyway
now that we got the promotion
out of the way
um oh you know what I got to call this
guy back he's doing a benefit for all
those poor people out there in Hawaii
Jesus Christ
what exactly happened
there was a fire during a hurricane and
it just blew around and killed a mind it
was [__] unbelievable
um
condolences to all of those people out
there
um so as always comedians we always do
benefits right as much you guys think
that we're a bunch of constant trash
people you know
when [__] hits the fan we always go down
we do the [__] show so I'll let you
guys know about that
um and I hope uh
I hope somebody's helping those people
out Jesus Christ
um all right
that was carrying me
that was me thinking of something other
than myself
in the last 10 pounds I need to lose oh
yeah I've been [__] working out
oh you know it
and when I go overseas I make sure I am
in the best shape both as a professional
where my ACT is and physically
I'm not gonna go over there and have
these [__] foreigners in their own
goddamn countries
oh my God I gotta call people foreigners
at some place they don't laugh but yeah
[__] you guys you [__] foreigners
that would be the ultimate
ugly American I'm doing it
um
anyway
I've been hitting the gym
guess what I did the other day I did a
[__] pull-up shoulders bugging me a
little bit but I did it I did a cup I
did one chin up like a week ago then I
did two of them I haven't done this [__]
since 2015. since I literally made the
bet with Paul verzi
that I was going to be able to do 10
Pull-Ups
when I was 70 years old the [__] was I
Dr I was drinking back then the hell was
I thinking I had no idea
when I'm like I literally made that bet
and that was the end of my youth
I think the universe heard it and was
just like wait a minute does this guy
still think he's Young
Jesus Christ he's gonna hurt himself
let's [__] uh let's uh let's snap a
couple of Rotator code whatever the [__]
I did I don't know what I did
Oh Billy bursitis Touch of arthritis
and tinnitus that's me that's where I am
arthritis bursitis and tinnitus and I'm
still going to be able to knock those
out
you know I figured by the time this is
the thing this is this is my wild card
because we didn't say I couldn't use
Peds
so I'm going to write out naturally
until I'm 69 years 69 when I'm 69 years
of age
if I don't feel I can do the [__] the
Pull-Ups
I I'm gonna do a cycle Oh Billy no neck
coming around with this [__] I'm
gonna be a jacked with that my [__]
turkey neck coming around the corner
busting out my Stevie Ray Vaughan InStep
tank top that nobody had seen since 1989
when I was at Great Woods
got a couple more freckles that [__]
day Johnny Winter was on that lineup
um
oh it actually feels good to be able to
lift my own body
you know and definitely want to do the
squats but the thing is you gotta
[__] stretch or make sure you're
doing [__] correctly I go to the gym now
and when I see these young kids you know
by young kids I mean 20s and 30s and
they're still lifting this gigantic
weight
you know I'm making those [__] noises
like did you just blow out your back or
did you have a [__] orgasm you know
those people
I remember telling you guys it was the
best one I ever heard
was there was a guy like I don't know 20
years ago when I was at a New York
Sports Club on the Upper East Side and
there was a guy used to come in there
dress like [__] Ken Patera and if you
don't know who Ken Patera is look him up
blonde perm with a [__] headband
and sunglasses
all right looking that like that dude
that we built like that [__] dude
that kept following Robbie Benson in
that basketball movie with the guy from
The Godfather Part Two remember that guy
I don't like your can with your oily
skin your greasy hair that guy he was a
he was the coach in that movie that was
a good movie
that Robbie Benson movie what was that
coach what did he say
you can take that scholarship he could
stick it in a sweat the red hot poker a
red hot poker
um
anyway
this guy used to come in right and he
had the short shorts he had the Ken
Patera [__] build with the [__]
beautiful noodle blonde hair
and uh and a headband and he had these
glasses that were like shaded and he
would go in and he would when he would
[__] put up his weight this is the
noise you'd make he'd go yeah
hey yeah
yeah
and the best one was one he never had
anybody spot him so that last one he was
squeezing out
he would go
yeah
you can hear it
through the whole [__] gym and every
once in a while I would catch some other
dude's eye and we would just start
cracking up laughing but nobody ever
said a word to that guy because that guy
had like he was on like Lyle Alzado [__]
like that guy if you said anything to
you he would literally tear your arm off
like a [__] chimpanzee
so anyway I'm I'm in I'm in the gym and
I I see these guys you know those guys
that do that dumb [__] with a bench
with like like the 120 pound dumbbells
and they got to put them on their knee
and then do like that [__] donkey
kick to get it up like
I don't I can't even tell you how
[__] stupid it is to do that
you are gonna be like
I mean I didn't even do that [__] look
what happened to me I am doing that
thing going like we had the same [__]
you know genetics I am doing that old
person thing where what happened to me
is gonna happen I'm just saying
just saying you can keep yourself tight
I've learned this now you can do just
lightweight lightweight you don't have
to even do High Reps you just have to do
it
just prevent [__] from sliding
listen people don't end up like me okay
oh speaking of me which isn't Ginger I
am like three quarters
of an album like I'm an honorary like I
could show up
at like an albinos only
party and when they look through the
door it could be like
come on
you know
can't do it for one One More Time For
Old Times Sake like Abe Vigoda and the
first Godfather that's two Godfather
references
in the first what
12 minutes
see people you're not gonna get that
with these other podcasts they're going
to talk about movies that people
actually saw as opposed to me who's
gonna talk about [__] from [__] 50
years ago
I wonder if the Godfather movies to like
young people is like me saying you
should you should watch
you know Gone with the Wind
laughs
um
just that whole idea of the mafia and
all that I think now they just look at
it like you mean corporations
aren't they doing that now but all that
[__] they arrested all those Italian
Guys for now was like legal
isn't that what's happening
I don't know so anyway we had a tropical
[__] storm out here
um I want to say we're in the eye of the
storm right now it's supposed to was it
heavy it's supposed to be at four
o'clock it's now 6 16
Pacific Coast time August 20th I think
it's starting to die down
um
I went full-on [__] dad mode
you know
that's what you do as a dad when you
know there's a storm coming
even if you can't fix anything you're
going to go outside do something
you know you're gonna move something
around get these out of here and [__]
put that in the garage I said put it put
you have no idea what's coming
I got the Weather Channel on
don't ask questions just do it you know
you're going to [__] general actually
I didn't do that I was outside all by
myself I got up on the roof
and I you know got the [__] trees and
[__] so I was just brushing all of this
[__] off of the roof
any little pile of something making sure
all the drains all the gutters were
cleared out
you know
total [__] dead hey there's a storm I
come in
batting down to hatches right and then I
then we have the drains and I made sure
that all of those things thank God I
[__] cleared those things out
um it's just unreal how much just like
dirt and [__] gets in them because it
never rains out here so they just
you know over the months that they just
fill up with sand dirt and God knows
what else is flying around the [__]
air out here so I cleared all of that
out and I gotta tell you
the water came down rolled off the
[__] roof into the gutters down the
spout around the [__] driveway off
the [__] property
and you think my wife said thank you
do you think even for a second
she went like wow
you risk breaking your own [__] neck
to get some goddamn pine needles off of
the [__] roof
she had nothing to say well I can tell
you right now I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna bring it up
tonight
do you have any idea what I did for this
family
should just laugh and roll her eyes be
like God Jesus
now that's my job I do the Meathead [__]
my wife is the brains of the operation
she's she plans [__]
and uh
makes my life great
she anticipates
you know the great ones anticipate and
then they create space so whatever
whatever the [__] else they say
and um
keeps it smooth
speaking of which
I remember last time I was doing Sam and
Jim's show Jim and Sam
and Sim
their show there on Sirius
and Jim Norton was talking about edging
and I was like what in the what is
edging
and he goes That's when you like having
sex and right before you're gonna have
an orgasm you stop
and then you wait for it to calm down
and then you get yourself you keep doing
that and evidently
you know
you're doing enough times and your
orgasm is more intense I mean who needs
a more intense orgasm
yeah my orgasms are pretty intense you
know but afterwards don't touch it don't
touch it right isn't that enough nope
got to go for these people they got to
go further
and
I found it hilarious and then
fascinating that
he was talking about that stuff so I
found this Sports version of edging
as far as it I'm gonna give you guys a
hint a team won a championship in the
last it was 13 years ago they won a
championship
they won it and about five people
realized they won it and everyone else
was sort of celebrating you guys know
what this is because the five guys that
were on the ice
who was it on the ice
it happened in Philadelphia
the filthy Flyers were in the finals
trying to break a [__] a 35-year
drought at that point
Patrick Kane comes down in overtime
they're up three games to two in front
of a hostile crowd at the Spectrum now
the Wells Fargo Center
he [__] somehow an impossible angle
scores a goal and the puck goes into the
net and went underneath the little apron
thing so no one could see it but he knew
it went in
by the way
that goal if it's real which it was
broke a
50-year drought
50-year drought for the blackoff so all
of Chicago
is ready
to have a sports orgasm
and nobody is signaling that it's a goal
but [__]
Patrick Kane is [__] skating down the
ice with the jazz hands going
ah look at it he goes and he goes to hug
the goal his goalie who made it insane
uh blocker safe
at the end of the third period where he
was falling he was he was dead to rights
and he launched himself towards the
shooter [__] cheese box
right out right off right off of it
[__] amazing right so he scores the
[__] goal and then like it took him
like three minutes and then they
confirmed that it was in fact a goal but
the fact that all of Chicago in
Blackhawk Nation the second it crossed
the goal line didn't all get to [__]
ah at the same time
I mean
there's never going to be a more anti
anti-climactic
overtime goal to win a Stanley Cup in
the end of 50-year drought ever NHL's
been doing this great thing just showing
um
you know the the deciding games on the
NHL channel you got to check that one
out
um if you get a chance
if you get a chance so
um
anyway so hopefully this storm is over
not too much damage you know I always
feel bad for when one of these storms is
coming along okay first off weathermen
because they have to predict the worst
it's their job
because if they don't everyone's gonna
be like what the [__] didn't you say
something
right
so then they diagnosed the worst and
then when it doesn't happen all these
morons
who can't even name a cloud just go
[__] weatherman
am I right
dude are they ever right are they
[__]
it's like people who go to the doctor
right and the doctor goes you're never
going to walk again and then they walk
and then they go like hey what are these
[__] doctors know they know way more
than you and they are they are they are
predicting the worse
the worst case scenario so a you won't
sue them and then B anything else is
going to seem like a [__] Improvement
you know what I mean
he said I was going to be [__] blood
for the rest of my life well look at
that stool sample
in your face
medical man right
and he's thinking in his head great he's
[__] happy he thinks I'm smarter than
me he thinks he's smarter than me and
Adam I'm not going to get sued fantastic
next
keep eating those cheeseburgers buddy
who do we got next
who's got next all right
well I feel bad for the weather man
and women and the weather days
uh
um
and the [__] Coast Guard
the Coast Guard is a [__] exciting
job except when there's a goddamn store
I mean there's a level of excitement to
it but it's all you're going to be doing
is rescuing one [__] jerk off after
another
like you figure most days
if you're in the Coast Guard you get
something exciting like a drug dealer
this guy's risking his freedom
gonna spend the rest of his life in jail
he's coming from a country where this
makes him seem like a good option
because the way the whole game's set up
in order for me to live like this you
have to live like that so he's rolling
the dice they're [__] flying after
I'm on the boat guns of [__] being
shut
somebody's on the loudspeaker you know
don't they asked whatever the [__] he's
saying right [__] pull that [__] over
[__] right exciting
exciting [__] but when a storm comes
you know
it's like there's no [__] reason that
they should have any work no reason that
they should have to put their life on
their line on the line that day but what
happens every time there's a storm you
know it a handful of jerk-offs are going
to take their boat out it ain't gonna be
that bad it'll be fine once we get out
in Open Water shouldn't be a problem
right and there's going to be about a
half dozen to a dozen jerk-offs who
decide to go surfing
and then they're going to get in trouble
and then these poor people who are safe
and dry now have to go out and risk
their life
I get the drug thing
I get risk in your life over that but if
some [__] if they say a [__]
typhoon's coming and some guy goes out
there on a wakeboard it's just like all
right man
evidently you don't give a [__] about
your life means nothing to you my life
means something to me
so I'm gonna stay right here
I always wish they would do that get a
call
mayday mayday whatever the [__] you say
Ahoy
I'm [__] out here yeah I don't have a
[__] engine quick
what the [__] are you doing out there we
told you not to go out there I know
well what do you think I'm gonna do get
in a [__] boat and end up like you go
[__] yourself why would you do that
they don't they go out and get them they
should leave them out there just sit
right back can you hear a tail a tail of
a faithful chip right it'd be like
Gilligan's Island meets Survivor
get like a little buddy
skip that
how abusive was the skipper with his
power huh smashing them over the head
with the hat used to be able to do that
um
well I've really talked myself into a
corner first of all I bring up The
Godfather
two and then Godfather one then I bring
up a Robbie Benson movie that's so
[__] old I can't even remember the
name of it and then how do I how do I
Dismount Gilligan's Island a show that's
so old everyone that's on it is dead
except for the woman that Tina Louise
still alive play Ginger
um
anyway
um I've been playing a lot of drums this
week
a lot of drums
uh
been having a good time man
just
it's funny I still play a couple of
Zeppelins so I can keep the foot where
it needs to be
butchering traveling Riverside blues and
and Good Times bad times
each time it gets a little better I can
fake it now
I wouldn't want to just sit down and
play it but I I could fake it I could
fake any real drummer be like wow man
that was [__] horrific
why would you ever think to do that in
public but everybody else would be like
hey that wasn't bad
do you play drums no
is that what those things are called
um they would be impressed
um
I was [__] around with uh my favorite
Lou Rawls song oh geez now he's talking
Lou Rawls what do you still read the
newspaper yes I do I love the newspaper
you know what it is I can stop the news
from coming in
if I don't like what I'm reading I go
[__] that and I turn the where's the
Metro region is this what's happening
[__] that I just always end up on the
sports page
you know but if you're watching the news
it just keeps coming at you right well
Bill you could grab the remote
well not if someone else is watching it
you know people come over their news
junkies immediately they got CNN or Fox
News on
those [__] people got nothing good to
say
but they're not talking about anything
you know what I mean
talking about ties and dumb [__] like
that and meanwhile you got the [__]
AI you know the most annoying thing if
somebody sent me something everybody's
been sending me all this AI [__] you
know what the most annoying thing about
[__] those AI robots I hate when they
pretend to think like they don't have
the answer
it's like what is that thing you [__]
one of these recording things you ask it
a question
and it goes
let's try something else what are you
saying for
like you're like you're a person
stop doing that
those stupid robots like looking up like
hmm you could speak every language you
[__] you have all the answers
just [__] say you know why they don't
do it
they're not going to do that with it
because they know how [__] annoying
those things would be
they want you to be comfortable
and just be looking at them like that's
what I do when I don't know the answer
right so then you're not intimidated
by how much [__] smarter this thing
is than you
what is the Fail-Safe with those [__]
look at that it just shut off my
recording
as I was speaking
as I was talking as I was soliloquying I
got this emergency alert National
Weather Service a flash flood warning is
in effect for this area until 3 A.M
oh [__] so here I am talking [__]
thinking everything's going all right
let's take a peek outside see what's
going on it says this is a Dane this is
dangerous and life-threatening
situation you know what that means some
jerk-offs [__] taking the cover off
his boat wow it's coming down now
all right now the storm is here holy
[__] Billy duck boots in effect do not
attempt to travel
unless you are fleeing an area subject
to flood or under an evacuation order
and you know what I'm going to do with
that information I'm going to listen to
it
[Laughter]
ain't no tough guy
you ain't catching me out there doing
the thing there that the dummies do
um
it is raining to beat the band
as they say
so anyway the reason why they're doing
this [__] is I'm [__] I should have
built an arc look at this stuff
um is
if those AI things actually just [__]
had the answer
right at the tip of their non-existent
fake ass [__] tongue
actually they're going to have tongues
right because the billionaires are going
to have their balls and ass licked
hey you still a bit about that man that
means there's somebody right now getting
their ass licked by a [__] robot and
there's people sitting there watching it
it doesn't feel like a ton I mean it
feels good but it doesn't quite feel
like a tongue what's the matter the
temperature there's something wrong too
cold nah it's actually a little warm
[Music]
all right bring the power down on that
one bring the power down
um what the [__] is going on and no
one's talking about so this is the deal
like you ever go around with hanging out
with some know-it-all [__] even if
they know everything and even if they
are smart it's still [__] annoying so
they gotta ask
looking around I don't know I don't
[__] know oh wait a minute there's
the answer
um
you want to talk about getting fished
falling in love with one of those
[__] things somebody's gonna do it
too I think most people are going to
because you're going to have
you know what makes a relationship hard
you know the number one thing that makes
a relationship hard is it's with another
person that has wants and needs
you know that's what you got to learn
you got to learn you know like the old
school politician they reached across
the aisle they shook hands right and
they both went out and shared a hooker
that's how things got done in this
country
AI they think just it's like having a
[__] dog
I riffed that one night talking about
how narcissists love dogs because when
they come home no matter what they do
the [__] thing's happy
like dogs behave how they want everyone
around them to behave
well these AI things are going to be
just like that I'm telling you
and you can thank God's America for it
uh
it all happened in the last [__]
three years
that's how it worked and then liberals
when Trump well you can thank Donald
Trump
you ever think of [__] reading have
you ever thought about that maybe
researching it
[__] countries bankrupt thank you Joe
Biden sleepy Joe it's uh you don't think
it's because we've had a [__]
never-ending War for 20 years it costs
like a [__] trillion dollars a month
or whatever they'll cost
that's what's so funny about these old
people saying that this generation is
soft it's like we've been at War their
entire lives and a lot of them served
you know
you know what's [__] up you can join
the military get a standing ovation at
halftime at a football game and then go
serve and 18 months later you're
homeless living under a bridge and the
same people that applauded you are now
screaming at you to get a [__] job
I don't think these kids are soft I
think what they're dealing with is they
get I mean we just used to have cocaine
we didn't have [__] fentanyl in it
right
we didn't have to worry about robots
that were [__] coming that you know
Gonna Roll their eyes around thinking
about [__]
it's like 9 000 degrees in Des Moines
Iowa right now that's our [__] food
supply
it's a lot of [__] going on I think you
have to be
I don't know
I just think that's what old people do
yeah it was like if I see one more
stupid [__] thing talking about how
uh
you know
people didn't complain in the 70s and
80s yeah they did
yeah they did there's just no video of
it
[Laughter]
uh my favorite one I actually commented
on the video
they were like before all this Instagram
video before all the electric car
[__] we had muscle cars
it's like first of all
you just skipped at least 20 [__]
years of American cars that were
designed to die at sixty Thousand Miles
and the speedometer went up to 80 miles
an hour what the [__] are you talking
about
all of those muscle cars ended around 73
or 74 and they were [__] gone and the
best you could do is a be like one of
[__] 200 people that got a Buick
Grand National or a you know IROC Z
there was a couple of cars but even then
they didn't they didn't move
they didn't have the [__] horsepower
they skipped over all of that and all
the electric car [__] it's like
I like how these people are like turning
like electric cars
into something that's saying you can't
have a gas combustion engine I love how
these electric cars but simultaneously
you can buy a [__] Hellcat
you can buy a BMW M series an AMG
[__] Mercedes
that [__] they have a Cadillac that
can go 200 miles an hour they did anyway
what are you talking about there's
plenty of them I just bought a Ford F250
6.7 turbo [__] diesel
no electric car people came they don't
give a [__] you could buy either or
electric cars are [__] amazing gas
combustion cars [__] amazing they can
exist simultaneously like people
back for all the [__] electric car
[__]
[__] scared children it's something
new I don't like it
keep it the way it was
wait a minute am I talking about myself
um
I brought up Lou Rawls earlier and I'm
not going to apologize for it okay so
[__] save your letters
all right by the way if you want to get
in contact with me you have to send me a
letter because I don't read emails
all right
send it to P.O box go [__] yourself at
freckles
Dot
net
Netflix
um
Lou Rawls I brought him up so my
favorite Lou Rawls song is Lady Love
your love is something like a Summer
Breeze my lady love
um it's just a [__] he the song is as
smooth as he is
and what I really like about it is the
drummer on that he's got a little intro
there
he's on the highest
and then he goes in this little Bossa
Nova um
they did those
the Ross doesn't talk like me right or
didn't right and he's playing a little
uh it's like bones
and 16th notes on the right
and he plays it for the whole song even
right through the bridge and it works
perfectly
works perfectly so I've been [__]
with that
if you guys were wondering what I was
[__] with on the drum kit
that's what I've been [__] with I'm
having a good time doing it
all right
and that's my right
to live my best boss in Nova Life
um all right I made a pie today
can you tell I've been inside all
[__] day
I made a pie today
I don't know why I just said you know
what do I have the ingredients yeah [__]
it I'll do it
it's been I've been uh Billy nice guy
today
I tell my wife was going through it a
little bit you know what I mean
I'm like you know what I'm gonna do
I'm not giving in to that energy and
make it about myself she's probably you
know
a little depressed that happens to me
all the [__] time so rather than
making about myself
like a douche
like the douche that I am I just decide
I'll just be I'll just
I'll handle [__]
I'll just [__] handle [__] I'll bring
her some food I'll give it water you
know
this is when you know you're you're a
bad husband is when you're actually nice
to your wife she goes why are you being
so nice to me
what'd you do what are you up pose
um
no she's [__] awesome I like being
nice to her
it's easy and it [__] makes my life
easy all right let's let's talk a little
bit and off all you [__] [__] out
there who just looked at your man and
was just like you see why don't you do
that well that's a two-way street lady
why don't you do it why don't you just
make him a [__] sandwich just for the
hell of it
huh you want to see his jaw hit the
floor
be [__] nice to him all right butcher
box everybody
butcher box and we're not talking about
the lady that the butcher is banging
this is something different butcher box
quality food should not be that hard to
find
well it is because once evil company
took over our food supply thank God for
butcher box trying to work their way
around it but today's day and age it can
be harder to figure out just exactly
what to feed yourself and your family
luckily
there's butcher box all of butcherbox
products meet the highest quality
standards you can find
with butcher box you can easily find
high quality Meat and seafood you can
trust
it's a hundred percent grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken pork raised
crate free and wild caught Seafood you
don't know what it's gonna do
humanely raised before it's
slaughtered no antibiotics or added
hormones this is drug free food
it gets delivered right you know I've
had the I bet the [__] chickens and
steer that live next door like come on
man try some of this [__] they're gonna
kill you anyway man you want to get high
try some antibiotic uh it's gets
delivered right to your doorstep with
free shipping always and customize
free shipping always and customized box
plans why do you have a comma after
shipping butcherbox gives you a variety
of high quality cuts and an amazing
value with exclusive member deals
oh member deal you got a jacket little
members only says butcher box right
above your [__] man tit recipe
inspirate
I know how to say that ins
whatever guides tips inspiration is that
we try to inspirate guides tips and
hacks
uh I resent that word hex
um that's what I'm cooking a steak oh
geez butcher box is giving us a special
deal sign up today at butcherbox.com
and use
codeburr to get salmon for three months
plus twenty dollars off your first order
that's butcherbox.com and use the code
Burr to claim this deal next up we got
oh look who it is old zip
recruiter
if you're hiring you know that it's
incredibly hard that's what she said to
attract top talent and with the current
labor market conditions it's even hotter
than ever that's why you want to partner
who gets it all zip appreciate it
the devil Reed recruiter zip recruiter
knows how tough it is right now but
they've figured out solutions for the
problem your the problems you're facing
see for yourself right now you can try
them for free at ziprecruiter.com
to reach more of the right people and
post your job to a hundred plus job
sites you need to hire as soon as
possible this smart technology finds
great matches for your job sooner want
first dibs on Talent zip
um lets you invite the most qualified
people to apply for your job team up
with a hiring partner who understands
what you need four to five employers who
post on zip will get a quality candidate
within the first day just go to this
exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
z-i-p-r-e-c
-r-u-i-t-e-r
dot com slash Burr that did not work out
at all again at ziprecruiter.com spell
outbur b-u-r-r supercruiter
the smartest way to hire
that's my favorite thing to read I just
love that pause it just makes me feel
professional like I should be looking
into the uh
the guy there the the music producer Bob
Rock through the window
I look at him it gives me a little nod
this beautiful hair starts moving I'm
thinking God damn it
that guy really had it all didn't he
the genetics The Ear The Hair the boots
the sport coat Simply Safe
um the average break-in lasts eight to
ten minutes now they get in they get out
huh that's what she said I love that
joke it's never old for me I don't care
so so fast so fast response is crucial
that's why Simply Save home security
launched its breakthrough technology 24
7 lifeguard protection to help stop
crime in real time now simply say
professional monitoring agents can
actually see speak
to and deter Intruders now why would you
want to throw and do something get out
of that house hey put that down I said
Put it Down where are you going
I want that job
can I do a ride along can I do a Sit
along and [__] Simply Safe I'm gonna
yell at some Intruders
uh the cops are on their way they're
Slim
um okay you broke a window the back door
was open you dumb [__] I would love to
just Heckle them
um anyway in your Smart Alarm Wireless
indoor camera simply say professional
monitoring agents can now warn Intruders
that they are being recorded and the
police are on their way in real time
stopping them in their tracks
before they take the [__]
you don't want to warn them too early
before the cops go that's a delicate
thing 24 7 lifeguard protection is made
possible by the new Smart Alarm Wireless
indoor camera available for the for the
fast protecting monitor plan I would
love to be on that [__] thing
I don't think this is your house
you seem a little confused there buddy
I don't think it's your house when you
got your face all covered like that what
do you say huh
all the good shits [__] uh downstairs
I don't know what you're doing up there
uh the new Smart Alarm indoor camera is
the only indoor security camera that can
trigger the alarm and instantly deter
Intruders with a built-in Sarah hey I
hope you know some Jujitsu because
you're going to jail buddy and you do
not want to get [__] in the ass do you
um prison rape that will stop anybody in
their tracks with Advanced monitoring
detection and vision AI oh God the Smart
Alarm well I hope it's not rolling its
[__] eyes pretending to think what do
I say you know what to say you robot
[__] the Smart Alarm indoor camera can
sense the difference between potential
Intruders and pets to reduce false
alarms
[__] freaking a dog out I live here
man 24 7 lifeguard protection and the
new Smart Alarm indoor camera Works
seamlessly as part of the entire
SimpliSafe security systems keep your
whole home safe from break-ins fires
flooding and more right now my listeners
get a special 20 off any Simply Safe
system when you sign up for a free month
trial of fast protect monitoring this
special offer is offered is for a
limited time only visit simplysafe.com
that's simplysafe.com
[Applause]
there's no safe
like simply safe
come on man nobody's Nobody Does that
pause at the end of the reads like me
there's nobody you know
this might be my ego talk
I might be thinking about the magnitude
of me my favorite Reggie Jackson quote
ever
um divorce court judge
oh boy
oh boy I don't envy anybody in that
situation dear freckles I'm a lady
listener and a huge fan of yours from
Saudi Arabia what's going on why don't
you come over to Abu Dhabi
I'll be over there wearing my [__] uh
my my Sunday best
in a couple of weeks uh this is my third
email so I'm keeping my fingers crossed
that you read this one all right this is
completely random but I wanted to share
it with you I just discovered divorce
court with Judge Lynn Toler
I'm imagining that's one of those judge
TV shows and quickly became a big fan of
both the show and the judge
I haven't heard of that one I also don't
watch that type of [__] I watch [__]
Kojak the other night
that's what I've been watching and I was
pleasantly just surprised I was looking
at this guy going is that Paul Anka Paul
Anka did a guest star
on Kojak I can't believe I did a podcast
with them I understand bringing up that
you wrote my way for Frank Sinatra but
how do you leave out I played a bad guy
on Kojak
that's how awesome that guy's life is he
forgets that he even did that [__] or
doesn't need to bring it up anyway I
randomly came across a live stream this
judge did she did during lockdown where
she was asked who would you like to meet
and her answer was Ron White Simone
biles Bill Burr
the first two were good and Barack Obama
all right she did all right on the first
two
I love that one of my current favorite
people is a big fan of one of my other
favorite people if you happen to be a
fan of hers then this circle is complete
um I'll keep this email short even
though I would love to express my
appreciation for your work all the best
to you and your lovely family go neek
yourself
all right I guess that's how you say it
over there n-e-e-k
um I have not last time I watched one of
those shows I used to watch
Judge Wapner when it first came out
I've read your complaints and I know
you've been sworn tell me would always
start he had Rusty
and uh it was a good show and then
somewhere during the Judge Judy phase
where she just was screaming at people
like sort of like uh it was like Hell's
Kitchen meets the like the courtroom
I've told you guys this before I tried
to convince Patrice to do this with me I
was going we're going to go on Judge
Judy and if you guys want to do this
steal this idea because I think it'll
work
all right I go here's the deal you sue
me or I'm suing you all right and then
you know after she makes her decision
you just pay me or I'll pay you and then
on the slide we'll just give the cash
back right but we would go on there
and our goal would be just how mad we
could make her
and you just keep a total straight face
and you don't listen to her and you keep
talking
you know but the thing is you act dumb
so she stays in her ego
you know so she just thinks she's
talking to somebody dumb
and I already like I didn't know what I
was gonna say but I'm good at pissing
people off I just knew when she was
yelling at me I was gonna go hey lady
Lady Lady
I mean that would have been it that
would have been like I don't know that I
could have kept a [__] straight face
I looked into the whole thing where it
was shot where it was booked and all of
that
and uh
one of my big regrets is we didn't do it
because nobody knew who the [__] we were
and if we got away with that would have
been [__]
hilarious to watch
um
but nothing is preventing you guys from
doing that I'm sure there's a judge out
there that's just screaming yelling at
people but I will check out that divorce
court person I am flattered that anybody
you know
always if anybody ever gives a [__] what
I do so thank you to the judge what's
the honorable what do you say
I was also Todd Rex would have been
perfect to do it with I brought that
idea up to him and he was imitating what
he would say
he was gonna call her your highness
well what happened don't you see there
your highness was uh
[Music]
I mean is there anything funnier than
that just [__]
I don't know I'm sure there is but to me
there isn't all right Judge Lynn Toler
the honorable Judge lintola thank you
for uh paying attention to anything that
my dumb ass does here all right book
suggestion
hey billfred Mann's earthband oh instead
of Manfred mint Earth band Milford
billford Mann's Earth band all right
let's see what we got here
um
what the [__] did I just do to my screen
go back go back I command thee there we
go
um um
I have a book suggestion you might
struggle a bit with the verbiage at
first because the guy writes like a bit
of a douche but it's fascinating
nonetheless
it's called incentive management by John
F Lincoln
is that a real name John F Kennedy
Abraham Lincoln John F Lincoln is this
another one of these coincidences
remember they used to do that
they both got assassinated he had an
assistant named Kennedy in the end of
this is the name wiggle
um I'm not finished with the book
although it isn't very long but the just
as far as I've gotten is that people
have latent abilities
that can be revealed through opportunity
what does latent mean hidden
um
for example women enter the workforce
when their men went to world war in
World War II they kept the country and
War Machine afloat when near none of
them had worked a job let alone a
production job yeah it's almost like
they're human beings with brains I think
that's more about sexism isn't it
[Laughter]
I love Rosie the Riveter like who the
[__] can't put a rivet in once they show
you you know it's all you gotta [__]
it's like it weighs a thousand pounds
you put on a thing and you [__] pull
the trigger right I don't know how to do
it but you know I could put on a bandana
and flex my [__] Alabaster arms
um
another example Babe Ruth
has his reputation because no one with
the ability to be better was given the
opportunity to do so
uh you mean a segregated League yeah
absolutely that's what I was saying the
guy played in an all-white League that's
why what this kid
Otani is doing down in the modern era a
hundred years later the fact that he has
the same stats Babe Ruth had at the same
point in his career and it just like
the President should be calling him
every other dog
you probably can't find the phone ah
geez um another example Babe Ruth
okay I already said that Lincoln gave
this example in 1951 don't shoot the
messenger
um I'm not shooting the messenger I
agree with that
if you look at you know once it was
what do they go once they broke the
color barrier you see what happened to
sports
right
um so it's safe to say that there was a
Pedro Martinez and a Big Poppy you know
Willie Mays there was all kinds of
people back during the Babe Ruth era
that just never
got to play
you know some Bartolo cologne they could
have hit a [__] Home Run for the San
Diego y ayottis way back then
um on top of
opportunity
oh wait he was with the Mets and did it
against San Diego right I can't remember
on top of opportunity people need a
reason to reach their full potential
which is where incentive comes into play
well you also need to be motivated you
should you should be trying to do this
for yourself
I work for Lincoln Electric and can say
they have absolutely stuck to the met
this management style I am a lowly
machine operator but I am well on my way
to finishing the year making 100K
because of my efforts
well that's fantastic anyway can't wait
to see you in Canton Ohio in November go
[__] yourself
listen I don't know what it sounds to me
is you had all this potential and you
read a book that made you aware of it
and now because of that you're making
some money so I'm very happy for you and
hopefully other people and listen
if if someone like me who went to summer
school you know
should have been all four years I only
went two years you know
to quote uh that guy with the fake heart
I had other priorities
Dick Cheney
um
other priorities like getting drunk
and being like I don't need this math
[__] uh song I hate that people oh I oh
my God
I [__] uh I opened a [__]
Pandora's Box here if that's that's if
that's the right expression
um
I brought up on my last podcast uh are
there songs that come on in bars or it's
sports sporting events or weddings and
everybody loses their [__] mind and
for the life of you you cannot figure
out
what the appeal is
and for me it was that song by Queen
Bohemian Rhapsody well I see a little
silhouetto of a man like what
what is happening throughout that whole
[__] song if anybody can explain I
would appreciate it it sounds like an
opera is it
I don't think it is I've seen operas
they're a little more impressive than
that
okay whatever
I don't listen to Opera so I'm going to
say it's like an opera
you know
that's like when some of my people look
at a band and go that's a funk band like
they'll say that about Led Zeppelin they
were actually a funk band no they
weren't and not even remotely
um anyway song I'm not saying they're an
amazing band but they are nowhere they
are in no way shape or form a funk band
if you want to hear them their attempt
at it listen to the crunch the most
unfunked song you would ever [__]
listen to in your life when that guitar
comes in my wife makes a face like
somebody just farted
um
all right
it's a fun song to play along to song I
hate that people love bill
a song people like that I [__] hate
is Fire and Rain
oh my God that song is like sticky ahead
in the oven
I've seen fire and I've Seen Rain
I've seen seven days and I thought would
never end
but I always wish I'd see you
one more time
I mean I know it's about a real tragic
event James Taylor's life but hey you
know
you got you got to bring everybody down
that's kind of weird you don't want to
be friends with James Taylor if you die
tragically he turned he [__] makes
money off of it turns it into a hit song
um goes out buys some more rollerblades
um I was going on about how bad this the
song is and someone at work said maybe
you don't get it
well I think that that's what it is
because these songs that I think are bad
I think I don't get them
because why would everybody else like
them
too many people like them
that it's it's got to be me right it's
Gotta Be Me
um everyone knows it's a song about a
friend who died and you guessed it James
Taylor thought
I'd always see you again it's pretty
straight [__] forward and the song
blows
please tell me you said that that's
[__] hilarious
yeah I know what it's about James Taylor
had a friend that passed away and he
thought you know I always thought I'd
see you again but you never know right
yeah it's not a metaphor
all right song I hate doesn't know
please keep these coming
um song I hate bill I understand why you
dislike Bohemian Rhapsody I dislike is a
nice word I [__] hate I don't even
know if it's that I hate the song I just
hate what it does to the average jerk
off eating a [__] plate of wings when
it comes on
I mean you think the Blue Angels were
flying over top
over the [__] over the Hooters
um yes I eat at Hooters
and I do go there for the tits all right
bill I understand why
why you dislike Bohemian Rhapsody I
personally like it but the song I hate
the most that everyone seems to love is
another queen song Fat Bottom Girls it's
much worse in my opinion
Fat Bottom Girls you make the rocket
world go round
I'm not a big Queen guy
you know
I love their drummer though
you know what I actually find with a lot
of uh Queen songs it's not their hits
it's the other ones I do like another
one bites the dust I'll flavor love that
one because Bryant Gumbel and Mike
adamly NFL 81 we're talking about the
[__] I think the Detroit Lions were
like 2-0 3-0 or 4-0
and they were showing Billy Sims
highlights while they played that
[__] song over
I get the chills when I hear that song
Another One Bites the Dust and seen
Billy Sims [__] high stepping into
the end zone the same way Carly Simon
speaking of James Taylor
Nobody Does it Better
they put that I think to Walter Payton
that was it I love that song I love that
song I had no idea it was a James Bond
song to me that was the Walter Payton
song
makes me feel sad for the rest
um a a gay man singing about a large
okay this person's saying Fat Bottom
Girls is much worse in my opinion
um
a gay man singing about large
uh fat chick type asses this isn't
something I can connect to
[Laughter]
well you know I mean he also you know he
kind of jumped around he was on either
side of the fence there wasn't he
he was figuring it out
um
I picture fat not thick I'm gross fat
chicks asses
that's because they they wrote it fat
right that it wasn't p-h-a-t yet
um and also there was no love
for for uh
women I guess they call them thick there
was no love from there was love
in the 1800s for and then somewhere
along the line I don't know what
happened
like you had as a white woman you had to
be [__] emaciated
um but that is not true in other races
as far as iPhone
um
in fact I remember just gonna forever
bring up Patrice we were [__] down
with that 7-Eleven is
right down near where uh The Wilbur was
and this woman came out he goes what do
you think about that bill too much ass
for you
and I was like yes
[__] ass weighs more than me
um all right picture fat not thick gross
fat chick asses in bad 80s jeans and a
flamboyant man convincing me to like
them I hate the whole thing
oh all right well
I mean I don't know I think
these are two great songs to hate
maybe you don't get maybe you don't get
it
you know it's maybe you love it so much
that you can't accept the fact that
somebody doesn't like it
I'm sorry I don't [__] like it all
right
guess what that's an extra [__] seat
you don't have to fight over at the
concert because I won't be there all
right overrated oh
macarons
there's a macaroons macarons what the
[__] are macarons hey Mr Bill
in the early to mid 2010s
it seemed like half of the U.S
population decided to open up either a
frozen yogurt shop
parentheses minimal complaints there
oh that is macaroon that's how you spell
macaroon or a French macaroon stand
I honestly don't get how those are that
successful
I will tell you there's nothing worse
than eating a macaroon that somebody
doesn't know how to
didn't make right because the the the uh
not the filling the the cookie part of
it it's it's like it feels like some
plaster from your ceiling fell down onto
some sugar
uh they're definitely good I'll give
them that but not a four dollar each
level of good
oh well this is why because it makes
people in my country feel like they're
in Europe
and then with the high price it makes it
almost feel like you got on a plane
that's what I would guess the person
says whenever I walk by those stands
they look completely deserted and their
Bakery displays looks nearly untouched I
guess at that price
at the price uh I guess at the price
that they're sold they only need a
couple of wealthy fatties
as returning customers to keep the
lights on does anybody work in a bakery
when you just bring out that
Thanksgiving onslaught of desserts every
day what do you do with some of those
fancy ones that don't sell
you wheel them out the next day be
honest anyway a person says that Ben and
Avid listener of your podcast since 2017
it keeps me somewhat sane it's kept me
somewhat sane for that entire period
well that's very nice of you okay well
all right so we got Bohemian Rhapsody
Fat Bottom Girls Queen taking a pounding
here and then we got uh we got uh James
Taylor
we saw a Fire and Rain
okay underrated movie James Taylor uh
what was it blacktop Hard Road blacktop
something blacktop look up James Taylor
movie
he's riding around in a 57 Bel Air
racing uh
this guy that has a 69 GTO I believe
two-lane blacktop underrated movie
during the beginning if not the the
height of the anti-hero cinema movement
while directors took over movies and had
Final Cut and all of that and you have
all of those masterpieces
um all right that is the podcast
football season
um we got that wide receiver from uh
bootay from LSU
had a nice touchdown running past
everybody and of course everybody in the
comments oh he's running by people that
are going to be working at Kinko's next
[__] week or third can do it's like
shut up you can't even touch your
[__] toes
I would love to hear the sound most
sports fans make when they tie their
shoes
that's why Crocs are so [__] Crocs
are for fat people you know who just can
lift up their heavy leg enough to slide
them into those [__] things all right
that's it everybody
go [__] yourselves I'll check in on you
on Thursday